hey everyone i'm lucy joined by jake and
phil
hello hey first point of order before we
get into the video
yes we are aware that copies of
cyberpunk 2077
are out in the wild gameplay is out
there
we're not going to be discussing any of
that stuff we're not going to be showing
it
and if you are fearful of spoilers may i
suggest
just as a as a general practice keeping
clear of the comment section
and the internet at large but it's fine
we're going to be discussing it in the
video
so now that's out of the way uh we are
going to be discussing
what sex and relationships are like in
cyberpunk 2077.
uh so phil you recently got to play 16
hours of it i played about four hours a
couple months ago
and one thing i didn't really get to
experiment or try out too much for the
relationships and that's something that
you actually did
kind of get to explore a little bit can
you go in depth at least as much as you
can with the 16 hours you had about
how that works because i know they said
they were doing some ambitious things
with it
in 2077. it seems like the way it works
is mostly
the more time you spend with people the
more you help them out the deeper your
relationship becomes and
it also seems like the game is paying
attention to your
dialogue choices um and the way that you
treat
people basically so not every choice it
seems like in this game is going to like
split off with a bunch of different
branches
in the story maybe there's a little bit
of different dialogue but you know
in choice-based games like this a lot of
the times
two choices will kind of take you in the
same direction even if the the pathway
is a little
different for either one but i do think
that the game is kind of keeping track
of what your attitude is like for
different people and how you treat them
and whether or not like they feel like
they can trust you over time
so my sense of it was that you know if
you
act nice to judy as you're helping her
out if you if she feels like you are
helping her out she'll
you know rely on you later for more
story quests
and then that could potentially grow the
relationship further as you
progress through her story it kind of
reminds me of how the bloody baron
worked in the witcher 3 and that you
meet him through the story
and then you get to a point where it
kind of branches off and he's got his
own little character arc but it seems
more involved in that but that idea i
think is a really good
idea because i think a lot of people
will say one of their favorite arcs
in the witcher 3 was the bloody barons
side arc which a lot of people could
have
entirely missed right yeah that's the
impression that i get to is that you can
blow past a lot of this stuff if you're
not necessarily like paying attention or
you're not prioritizing it
you know you're gonna get communications
you're gonna um from various characters
they're gonna
hit you up on the on the phone and then
you
like have that quest logged in your
giant pile of side quests i had a huge
number of side quests
at the end of my playthrough um
and like when you get to it you can
progress that further if you don't ever
get to it you might miss that altogether
it seems like they're not timed or
anything there's no
um way that you'll miss out on that
stuff other than not doing it at all
so there's that at least because you'll
have a lot going on
so you say they hit you up is it very
much a case of like hey cousin let's go
bowling
or is everything to do with you know
just quests
that they're giving you or other
opportunities to just hang out with
people
so i did kind of ask about this i did
bring up whether or not we can go
bowling
um i didn't get like a super straight
answer on it but my
my feeling is that like it's not going
to be quite as
you know hangout b pals as that it's
much more of a
you're going to get messages on your
phone that are like hey can you come
help me with this thing or hey i have a
dire situation or
hey uh we're gonna go meet up with
someone else it's gonna lead to a story
quest but you know
that sort of thing it's not just like
shooting a pool with somebody or
whatever
um they do though just hit you up
a little bit for conversations that was
a thing that seems to happen especially
as you grow your relationships
you'll get i got texts from judy that
were just like hey how's it going how
are you
you know how are you holding up you're
going through a lot of stuff that sort
of thing
um and i think those also count toward
expanding the relationship and maybe
unlocking further story quests
if you get back and you know fire up
your phone and just like hit replies
make choices on that um all that stuff
seems to be like going into a big
aggregate pile of
how your relationship is going and leads
to more side quests and
from there i don't really know i didn't
actually finish out any of the quest
lines so i'm not sure exactly how far
the relationships go
uh in that regard but that seems to be
the way it works
so i was gonna ask is there any way you
know in a tell-tale like esque way
you can say you know judy didn't like
that is there any
way of understanding how i guess well
you're doing in a
when you're having a conversation with
someone or building that relationship or
is it based purely on
you know there's no meter anywhere
capturing how well your friendship is
going
it's just all based on how the character
reacts yeah i think
it's all just you have to like know how
people
are you know it's a lot more like your
actual interactions with actual people
it doesn't log as far as i could tell
any
sort of you know standing meter
there's no you know paragon rogue sort
of
understanding of how you're doing with
anybody you just kind of have to go by
what
you think they how they react to you and
what you think they need as a person
it's pretty pretty organic in that way
i think one thing you mentioned earlier
was that people would hit you up on your
phone or whatever it might be in the
cyberpunk universe
is there a like how does that work how
do those conversations
work is it just oh you're phone buzzed
and you've got a
one of two replies you can pick yeah
pretty much that um
you have the little phone icon down at
the bottom of the screen at all times
so you can pull up your phone you can
make calls you can get in touch with
people
i'm not really sure how deep that might
go i
you can fire up anybody you've interrupt
interacted with
and uh you know get them for side quests
or whatever there are times when you
need to
call people for story things um but
mostly like
when they're interacting with you it's
like receiving a text message on
your phone at home and you just pull it
up when you're ready for it
you get a little buzz and like i said
you can
neglect that and pull open your phone
and have 40 messages
from various people i had that happen so
like
they're just kind of sitting there
waiting for you um but yeah it's just
it's mostly just uh text interactions
where you have
one or two replies um at your disposal
and
you know like interacting with people in
conversations it feels like
those choices might matter in a way that
you don't
necessarily see all the time so
you know try to treat people the way you
you
want to be treated that sort of thing i
guess all right and speaking so
obviously there is another character who
is in your head at all times johnny
silverhand uh played by keanu reeves
obviously
you might have seen him in some
marketing you might have seen him
um what's that relationship like then is
he just
on screen the entire time or does he
just pop out to say hello
at certain moments in the story when it
makes sense so it's
more the latter he is around all the
time
and he is interjecting in story beats um
here and there he just kind of like
appears on on the scene
and he wanders around in the background
or he'll come and sit down and talk to
you
you'll often have dialogue choices
for johnny as you're interacting with
somebody else
as well and like you can
maybe choose between those you can kind
of blow him off if you want
but your relationship with johnny is
also one of these character
relationships that seems to be
evolving and changing over time as well
i had
the um cd projekt dev who was kind of
watching
over my shoulder virtually as i was
playing ask me
what how i felt about my relationship
with johnny it's something that you
develop over time
and it's interesting because the story
set up for johnny
is kind of an antagonistic one like you
get that weird biochip in your head as
part of the story
that's what brings johnny into your life
he's kind of your imaginary tyler durden
friend
um but the stakes are that
that biochip is killing your character
and
the way it works is johnny's trapped on
it and it is
designed to like take over your body and
turn you into johnny silverhand so like
you know you're kind of not on great
terms with him to start
he's sort of a bad influence on you
um but how you treat him can change i
guess that situation
potentially i kind of took him in a
positive direction i felt like we were
more allies
than uh antagonists and we were kind of
working toward the same goals but
he's an independent person even though
he's in your head
and he has an agenda of his own so i
don't really know
exactly where that all would have gone
or whether
it's the greatest idea to be best
friends with the
machine that's trying to take over your
body i'm not sure exactly
it feels like a reminder when you said
that you um you know you're having a
conversation with an extra character and
you can say things to john it reminds me
a little bit of
uh capricorn 6 and guys walter in battle
style where
it's the figure in the head that only he
can see that only you can see
and you're still trying to have i
imagine that's going to be some good
comic relief moments when you're trying
to get something across
to two separate people with two very
different uh
end games i guess yeah it's similar but
not quite the same because you can talk
to johnny without
speaking out loud so you you're like
talking to him in your head basically
um so you don't have to play two
conversations at the same time like in
bsg which is one of my favorite things
about that show though so it's kind of
it's kind of sad we don't get that um
does
do those interactions with johnny happen
pretty naturally like could you just be
walking around the city and he could
show up and be like hey what are you
doing
or are they more story based like okay
here's a cut scene better expect johnny
to show up at some point
they tend to happen when things are
happening in the story
but then again everything is kind of the
story right like you're doing side
quests and stuff he's in
he's part of side quests he's popping up
all over but he'll also
pop up like when you're on the way to
another place for instance like you've
got an objective you're kind of headed
toward
but you might be you know diverted by
some side quests or whatever or
random things that happen on the street
and so like just
in transit you sometimes have johnny
popping up and talking to you he's just
like kind of ever present he's not
always on screen he's not always
interacting with you but he is always
kind of like paying attention
and he will also like give you advice
and you don't necessarily have to take
it but he like he has a sense of how you
should act in any given situation
there are characters that um you know he
knew from his life
50 years earlier that he'll have input
on you don't necessarily have to take
that and i think that
all counts too toward the idea of like
how your relationship with him is going
and what that might lead to and i don't
actually know i didn't get that far
so we'll see how it develops it's wild
to me and then
we saw those reports uh from earlier
this week too that a
a cdpr dev has put like 170 something
hours in and still isn't at the end of
the game so
definitely don't expect you to have all
the answers uh especially because i
imagine some of those arcs are going to
be very
very long but i know in the title of
this video
we've also put how does sex work in
cyberpunk we talked a little bit about
it last week
um because obviously it's a very mature
game and
it's it's you know we've seen uh sex
workers
in some of the trailers they've talked a
little bit about it
what was your kind of overall impression
of how it's tackled in the game
i think especially comparing it to how
it's tackled quite comically
in the witcher 3 yeah uh i feel like
it's
similar to the witcher 3 um not
necessarily the same it's a little more
straightforward and a little more
graphic
but you know not especially so
you know like there's they it doesn't
push too far like the
cd projekt doesn't want people banning
their game and stuff so like
um there's some full frontal nudity it's
basically like you
say you find a sex worker you can
interact with them you can pay them
you cut to a cut scene of you know
getting down to it and like it's just a
sh it's like 30 seconds of you know
moaning and like
movement and uh a little bit of new
fades out
yeah exactly like mass effect love theme
plays
right it's like i said it's a little
more
like not quite pornographic but a little
bit more than the witcher 3 the witcher
3 is kind of like
soft about it i feel like and this is a
little more like yeah but
it's about as much as you can get away
with it exactly right
i was gonna say and i use this with the
heaviest of quotation marks but as
realistic as you can get
in a futuristic gritty
setting like the one that cyberpunk is
set in yeah while also feeling like a
video game
i was gonna say and i mean it's not it's
just kind of like
a thing that you can do in the game why
it doesn't have like
stat buffs or anything from gta or
whatever
yeah seemingly no it's just a thing you
could do if you feel like doing that
um as for how those sort of
relationships
might pop up in the story or like affect
your relationships with other characters
that i unfortunately have no idea and cd
projekt would not
tell me i didn't get far enough
interacting with any
character um to like create a
relationship like that
i don't know how that might have changed
anything if it is possible
um but yeah the the one just like find
somebody on the street and pay them
interaction that i that i tried was
pretty like sectioned off it didn't
really have anything to do with anything
it's just a thing you can do
like buying food in the game is a thing
you can do or getting clothes
it's just didn't really have any effect
on anything it's just one of those
things that makes the city i guess feel
a little more real but
you know just as sort of out there i
guess it definitely kind of leans into
the uh
liberal hedonist lifestyle that
they kind of you know that's the core of
night city i guess it's like you can
have anything you want as long as you
can pay for it
yeah there's absolutely a lot of that
basically underpinning everything
going on in the game sex is basically
everywhere
all the time so yeah it feels like just
one of those things that kind of plays
into that theme in the feel of the place
without necessarily
mattering too much more than that all
right well i guess we can see
for ourselves in a couple of very short
weeks when cyberpunk
actually comes out it feels very strange
to be able to say that
but for everything to do with cyberpunk
2077
we'll have you covered here on gamespot
[Music]
you